c'est une petite révolution pour cette
commune et ses 1600 habitants située au
coeur de la plaine de versailles un
village rural au charme d'antan mais un
peu coupé des communications numériques
mardi 7 novembre une armoire de montée
en débit a été inaugurée sur la place de
l'église
un événement attendu par les locaux je
pense surtout aux entrepreneurs
indépendants qui sont nombreux dans le
village dont qui travaillent sur place
et qui ont besoin d'une d'une
informatique de de qualité de pouvoir
travailler vide de communiquer vis tu
t'es moyenne elle était justement sa vie
à une journaliste qui disait un instant
qu'elle avait 0 3 dans sa propre maison
qui est au qui justement là nouveaux
écarts debasement ceux qui sont à loire
ils ont admis hélas alors la montée en
débit permet d'atteindre en moyenne de
l'ordre de 15 méga 500 foyers seront
alimentés par cette armoire dès février
objectif à terme accueillir la fibre en
2020 un défi lancé depuis 2016 par le
conseil départemental avec la création
de l'établissement public yvelines
numériques 7 millions d'euros déployés
pour quoi d'abord pour lutter contre la
fracture numérique
il ya aucune raison que les la majorité
des 262 ville de notre département soit
équipée et certaines d'ores et déjà de
très haut débit et que d'autres soit
entre guillemets les c'est pourquoi
comme base non 44 autres communes vont
être équipés d'armoires de montée en
débit dans les prochains mois près de
quinze mille foyers sont concernés